what's happening there reject nation we
back at it for the next episode of
superman and lois season two just got
renewed for season three congratulations
you guys are a good show hey why don't
you go ahead and check us out on patreon
that's where you'll get the full length
reaction watch along for superman and
lois along with a bunch of other shows
that we cover as well and if you can't
do that least you can do is leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated don't
treat it like it's kryptonite especially
that subscribe and notification bell
look how i'm tying it in then prepper
boys thanks for helping us edit it down
you guys are so cute
let's do it
like your french navigation system
not looking too good
it's fine
how long was she out there for
hey
is it okay to come in yeah
of course oh it's you superman i'm so
happy you can finally come home john you
have no idea lois look all i want to do
is spend time with my two girls you know
what
that's not mom she's still gone
i know
not the kind of nipple chills i wanted
how's your debate prep coming
good
emily's been helping me
if you uh you know if you need another
opinion or something no i'm good i'm
good forever thank you probably cheap
with your opinions huh yeah
they canceled the season we had to
forfeit all the wins
first time in smallville history
because of you
damn whose drugs were those
no dad you don't understand no john i
don't understand
i thought my son had a little more
integrity than this
[Music]
i'm sure it's about anderson it's
perfect timing as always yeah well this
time it actually is
otherwise i would have lasered you
you stopped
kello
he's gone
forget
you killed him
i had no choice
backwards name tag
we can finally ascend
yeah i know what that means i know what
that means
i need you to tell her
my other self
what
everything you said was true
i saw it all
i saw me
that's how you become the best version
of yourself
by merging with your shadow self
get that shadow work boy
she told me
to tell you
come now
well then we should go
and all become gods
god's among us just like the mormons
chris if at any point you feel
uncomfortable i know i'll call you lois
is there a chance to really figure out
what's going on with ally
we may not get another one
i gotta go
the totally unsuspicious van is here
you sure you want in on this
for the story of a lifetime
absolutely
put this bag on your headphone
i usually see if you called lois in your
recent history
they're in hazmat suits
is that a problem
nope
seems totally normal
then get in and put it on in the way the
last suit you'll ever wear
i couldn't hear you did you make a quick
game joke was that what it is it made a
minute
so um you guys are just friends now yeah
just friends
i was actually kind of hoping that maybe
we could all hang out
oh
[Music]
sarah what's going on i'm following me
into my school
i kind of need you to jordan
yeah yeah okay cool i'll i'll message
aubry right now all right i can't wait
to meet her and you'll get your money
okay just chill out that's not how this
works hey
leave her alone
let's get this pendant so you can figure
out a way to destroy it
section 3a
clear ew anderson
i'm sorry
you're not sorry at all
it's time
[Music]
prep your recorder chrissy
anderson knows about ally
when i was locked up with towel i told
him to look into her chrissy's on her
way to see ally right now she said it
was something big
i'm tired of feeling incomplete i
finally see the way through what a weird
group chat
looks like she's at home
you track lucy's phone
do you track my phone
what if they're trying to get into the
inverse world the other superman he came
through a portal in the mines do you
think lucy could be with chrissy and
ally the dod has a security team there
let me make a call
good thing you've been reinstated man
the upside down
time is finally here
oh
i hope you don't incinerate man
this isn't supposed to be happening of
course not the team at the mines isn't
responding
whoo
just save chris hey come on no one else
matters
[Music]
oh it's great yeah
that hbo money
no
oh
god you just had to do it didn't you
we're the only ones that you see
that's your first thought i mean you saw
what like how about
god damn
thank you it was like something out of
walter guys or stranger
stargate i know this must be strange
strange
you look exactly like the guy who killed
my mom
he's not the same guy then why do i
worry all the time that when he's around
you you're gonna end up just like mom
you should watch season one
she's a drug dealer john jordan she's
doing a doubt about her dad okay it's
just the two of them and if they get
kicked out they'll literally have
nowhere to go and you care about it that
much you're the only one that can do
something sketch to help their
girlfriend
well you've been a part of this since
the beginning there's no one else that
could really help so
good excuse to see him you want one name
and she is only a priority to you now
who else
was there and deep down
deep down you are so afraid you girls
are going to leave you the same way your
wife left jesus ally oh that i can help
you phil
the same way i helped lucy
tell me where my daughter dad
dad it's good yeah tap loisen
mirrors
reverse uh symbolism
this was lucy's choice
she's dad lois no she's not how are you
gonna keep scandaling i never brought
scandal into our house you did but
because i'm a woman
this is now a commentary on me and
that's not fair and it's all because of
your stupid mistake
wow now say exactly that
maybe you just needed to
get that out of your system just take a
breath you didn't really beat it you
know
you're saying stuff you know
it's the politics
how you respond to it in the face of a
crisis
is it with honesty and integrity because
i will never waver when it comes to
trying to do what's right for my family
and for this town you just got yourself
a vote vote lotta for mayor i love it
sorry about nab earlier oh
don't be she uh
bit of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it really tucked some sense into her
you did get hurt helping me
and if any of your injuries these
injuries are temporary this can't get
back clear okay yeah there might be a
few more moments of confusion but i'm
gonna be okay pretty soon lois and i
will be out of your hair
her me and now will be a family again
you'll have all the time in the world to
superman it up
lois
there is no way that lucy would go to
another world and only send a text
there's nothing else here
i checked but she can't just leave
oh
why didn't they keep leaving me oh
but she wasn't there right
i was like not obviously there i can't
just i understand but he threatened to
hurt you if you didn't pay him
your brother heard that
you don't have to worry okay i'm gonna
stay over at kim's tonight can i at
least walk you there
okay okay
and then after tonight that guy's gonna
drop it nice mr all the way okay good
first day can't thank you sir
super first step nothing feels very
ominous about this whole thing hey this
is why i love you even when things are
bad you make me laugh
love
oh
yeah
maybe
thanks for enabling me john
and there it is
the sneakiest truck in all small
get in the car candace
she's not going anywhere hoping you'd
see that
oh [ __ ]
jordan time to activate your powers what
if jonathan's powers become activated oh
my mind is spinning
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh wow that
terrible fall like a fish
good luck finding those
now you're dead
oh
god damn oh
oh boy oh boy
damn
except the oliver queen mask
jordan knock his block off
all that training
and your little car too
look at me
ever go anywhere near her again anywhere
that's the name after you understand
yeah yeah okay i stripped the car for
pieces and sell it
pay off candace is dead
well natalie i want you to have a choice
including whether or not you want to get
to know me
instead of
being forced to live in the same house
with me
what are you saying
bought you a house an old friend of
mine's had a place for rent for a while
i thought maybe you and your dad could
check it out and then maybe
you and i can get to know each other
maybe uh you're living rent-free get to
know
it's the least you could do
guys did you look underneath the couch
he's in the cushions
[Music]
[Laughter]
no way
we're wearing these suits and it was
dark in the mines so she was there yeah
i guess she got spat back out can i get
you anything are you hungry actually i'm
pretty wiped i just that do you mind if
i of course of course i'll take you home
why don't y'all stay here for the night
she's manipulating you guys to get allie
out of the dod
he's just a repair shop i'm sure the
living area is better
so he's getting a spin-off right that's
what's happening it must be john henry
chronicles
it's perfect
you sure cause
clark said that everything we need is
right here
allie didn't have the pendant
then who does
jonathan has the bit
what took you so long to get home well i
promised candace i would walk her home
no no you are either at the house or at
the store anywhere else you need our
permission i doubt he's lying clark
the problem is he's getting really good
at it
why don't you just spy on him
[Laughter]
just hover above the coins
won't know
am i gonna stay in my place tonight i'd
love for you to see it i have fresh ice
cream
you you used to
dad
are you okay he's he'd been drugged you
know god
told you she's the bizarro lucy
it's functional lucy bizarro loosely
something in my teeth
yeah sorry i was sort of the fail safe
in case things didn't go according to
plan
uh why
to make sure ally
gets to the other side
i should have called that
yeah
you couldn't have seen that coming it's
not possible
they duped us all
[Music]
you see i said i said that about her in
her sarcastic way with the tone in case
i was wrong
[Laughter]
safeguarding it's discarded that way if
i'm wrong it's just greg was making a
joke
i'm right fred got a theory correct it's
called the sarcasm escape hatch
that's right the cowards lie
there's so many bad guys hmm and they're
all closing in
so many bad guys i think they're going
to break out morgan edge
and they're going to fight the baddies
together
morgan edge might sacrifice himself in
the end but then he's a good guy yeah
ultimately yeah for brother brother i
think that's what's gonna happen i'm
just calling it and lately
my commented skills had been
that's me hitting the target with an
arrow
so yeah that was uh that was that was
good it was good another good episode
terrific episode
fantastic stuff as always what's your
favorite part john favorite part
favorite part of the whole episode my
favorite scene was probably uh with
jonathan and jordan on the highway tbh i
mean it was just very gratifying to
watch jordan have to spring into action
use his powers i like the kind of
tearing down of the wall between the two
of them that's happened they've still
got a lot of tension between john and
the parents and you know all that stuff
clark giving him the cold you know
treatment and everything but to see the
way that he and jordan are slowly kind
of coming back together and starting to
behave like brothers again and jordan's
helping him out and he makes that
sacrifice and he doesn't make a huge
deal out of it like it was it was a
moment that made me appreciate just how
far we've come with those two we come
far with everybody but i i really uh i
don't know for whatever reason that
really stuck out to me in an episode
full of a lot of lovely little character
beats and moments and whatnot you know
they never lose sight
of the emotional beats you know amid all
the science fictiony stuff but yeah you
know
in the array of things you kind of know
were gonna happen uh that was a nice
development and uh yeah it's just
gratifying to watch him kick a little
bit of ass and use his pal like i love
the way that it seems like jordan's
powers are specifically attuned to
things having to do with his brother
um and you could argue that maybe that's
a plot device and a mechanic uh but for
the way it's presented here i've
actually kind of enjoyed that sort of
extra bond of brotherhood that it seems
like uh jordan's powers kind of manifest
there and and the way in which john has
looked out for him so much over time now
he's looking out for him in a way that
feels less like he's trying really hard
and more like he's just you know
actually looking out for him and so uh
so yeah that was
that was perhaps my favorite moment in
the episode worried for for the boy for
standing up uh sarah and uh and her
friend
it's a bummer
it's definitely gonna uh you know create
some friction with their relationship
but uh yeah i like the tension coming
out of that as well that whole thing
about like i had to sneak back here i
wasn't gonna tell them you know it's
nice i mean that one guy you gotta hope
that he doesn't uh
you know
rat out john uh jordan for having actual
kryptonian power
uh although i guess he could have just
assumed it was xk but you know it seemed
like
it was clear to him that it was a bit
more serious than that so uh you know
i'm a little worried that that is gonna
lead to some kind of thing where he gets
exposed or whatever but uh
yeah that was a very solid sequence what
was your favorite part of the episode i
don't think a guy knows i was jordan
that hood
really is a
very effective face covering
this guy clearly hasn't seen some cw
shots of course
sorry i know oliver queen yeah yeah the
hood the hood's enough there's a reason
he had his hood on of course because
yeah it's an impenetrable disguise
in a world
where all clark has to do is take his
glasses on and off i'm pretty sure he's
disgusting that's true absolutely but
now that's what jordan needs now is he's
gonna have to get a pair of groucho
glasses or something to to really
disguise himself what are you doing at
my house
shortage don't don't ever put those
glasses on in here yet
without preparing us
that was a really rewarding scene it's
the most exciting scene i like
everything they're doing with lana i'm
really i'm really
happy with how they're flushing that out
it feels the most disconnected from all
the other stories though
weirdly
because she has this whole plot of like
running for mayor
and then this
fallout with her husband
yet
it's kind of
like not tied into everything else
that's happening but the way they're
developing it is really really engaging
and i think they're
fleshing out a really strong character
for lana on
handling a separation handling a divorce
and knowing how to comment on situations
like real life things that happen like
divorces are so common if i'm not
mistaken 79 of marriages and in divorce
only 21 success rate
so you're seeing what 79 percent of
married couples go through and this
that's an actual statistic i want
everyone to take me seriously on that as
possible
uh i think that the way yeah they're
handling hers is really awesome
the way the men write her character
it's really good
i don't know who the writers are it's a
matter of it to be honest i really don't
know
um
and uh it's a that relationship is
fascinating like it was a real like
nuanced beat when she found out that he
got his own place or something that
feels more real and tangible about oh
this is
we're really separated you know it's
like that kind of thing where you're
you're in that separation phase and you
still feel like connected or there's a
chance subconsciously you know i imagine
that's partly why
you pick up on more
nuanced details of her performance of
like the fact that she invited kyle back
in
for this
subconsciously reads to me as like well
she still wanted to be around him she
still wanted to connect with him and
talk with him maybe use some of this as
an excuse to air out some stuff you know
the way how some things did manage to
penetrate through
so i really love what they're doing with
her especially
in terms of our other players uh i think
everything's pretty solid you know i
like the tension with um
there's some stuff that i i'm not a big
fan of like i i'll get to that i love
the way they realize going to the they
call it the other side here
it's always something so basically the
other is the inverse
inverse world first world or something
like that yeah
it's always something so basic with
these like
you know parallel backward topia yeah
reverse land river
yeah yeah uh with going to to that i
thought the way they visually realized
that was awesome
um
some of the rules were a little muddy to
me so it's like do you need the pendant
to cross over is that why anderson was
able to successfully cross over while
everyone else was like oh god what's
happening to me
incinerated [ __ ]
but ally was also like oh [ __ ]
i just now supposed to go
what's going on here no
no no
no that was uh that was
i'm curious on what the motives are here
i'm kind of worried this season like as
great as this episode was a few nitpicks
are there
um which i could rattle off in a second
i'm a little worried this season might
not stick the landing as strong as the
first season
because there's there's so many pieces
here there's so many things happening
it's like who's the real back well it
all come together in the end you know
like you have anderson you had bizarro
in the first half
and really it's ali
that's about it it's really just a lot
of it
but even when like it elevated anderson
to like i'm the real i had a plan and
manipulate and get to the top here of
this world i just learned about like a
day ago
um like i i don't know what's going on
there is it is it the alley in the
inverse world who manipulated him into
doing that you know um is is the real
baddie the inverse alley so just seems
like there's a lot going on and i'm kind
of wondering if all like coalesce that
we gotta deal with like lucy's stupid
predictable [ __ ] and that annoys me it
does it was like it was pretty uh it was
like so remarkably predictable on how
that was all gonna go like she's not
really dead we didn't see it happen
they're mourning over nothing great
acting in those scenes
fantastic acting love lois in the
apartment being like i'm looking
everywhere i've looked in this bookshelf
i've looked at this phone i don't know
where she is and clark hug me hold me
love me that was a really great scene
even uh papa and papa lane breaking down
about the whole situation was really
really good like but him going into the
interrogation room like come on dod be
smarter than that would be a bunch of
[ __ ] morons what happened if they're
too close to this case you know don't
they say that in movies and shows
usually when you're like a police
department but you think a dod would be
smarter to be like you're too close to
this case well yeah and also too i mean
i i thought that while it's well within
character for ali to be able to get
under his skin because of the personal
connection i was also like
she got to you really fast yeah yeah you
should have
did this yeah so i thought that was a
little
like
like i get it you're doing it for the
dramatic effect and it was ultimately
nitpicky because what do i want some
like boring ass scene of them sitting
behind the glass watching some dude i
don't know interrogate her no every doll
would be boring
um
so it's like i'd rather have this scene
than that inverse
however uh yeah it just like kind of
pulls me out a tad bit but i'm like come
on man get her [ __ ] together lucy
predictable sarah
and you're going through divorce
with your parents
you're kind of annoying though sometimes
man i gotta say like you're kind of
annoying even the way you approach
jonathan about like you just try to
understand me and where i'm coming from
and my thing
and i can't help but be annoyed like i
know i'm supposed to i know i know what
you defenders and your little comment
boxes are saying of how
she's a girl and you know it's like i've
said some stupid [ __ ] in my life too
when i was younger i studied stupid
stuff this day that gets me in trouble
at the same time
you know i'm just giving you my honest
feeling and my honest feeling when she
says that is god that's [ __ ] annoying
you're like this is don't you understand
that in john and jordan's eyes that's
who you cheated on him with there's no
other way to put it into a different
perspective he dropped that [ __ ] pretty
fast for you and now you're like
yeah she's the only girl who's ever been
divorced and who's ever had divorced
parents so i'm gonna be friends with her
like find someone else in this school
that you can maybe talk to
um
really fair i mean yeah it is a little
bit like i i suppose you could liken it
to like uh i don't know uh
lana or yeah lana being like hey kyle
let's go get lunch with tonya you know
like let's go get get food with or let's
meet up with the person you cheated with
i mean obviously uh lana saying that to
kyle
i'm not gonna get the the motivations
right there but it's basically akin to
having the three of them all get lunch
together is what you're saying is like
you know it's yeah it's the person that
you cheated with and now you want me to
make nice
uh
even though it's not quite as advanced
degree as you know like a six-month
affair or whatever kyle had but
but yeah there is a little bit of uh
i don't know i i i
this episode hit me the first time this
show has hit me with a sense that while
i still really enjoyed all the scenes i
felt like the scenes were getting like
really short like there were a lot of
really short scenes they're still good
at making the dialogue feel natural and
the performances are still really solid
in those scenes but i feel like a moment
like that could have had some more
nuance or something on top to maybe uh
i don't know alleviate that because i
don't begrudge them the whole thing
about like this girl is like you know we
were super close before and uh and then
you know this kiss thing and then we
just split apart because that now we're
you know like getting back together and
then making friends again
but yeah i mean like there is a certain
aspect of like you know jordan whatever
you're feeling about it just just stow
it you know where uh yeah we could do
with the little uh i don't know she went
to meet with her
without even
telling him
messed up
bottom line cheated
she cheated and she met with the person
to almost destroy that situation almost
destroyed their relationship
sure yeah
there's no shirt this is just his
objective this is what happened in the
show did you not see the show that's
what happened in the show
yeah
it's all in the chat it's all there
count it it's all fair
so yeah and then she just approaches him
like hey i did this and i kind of expect
you to be cool with me going to lunch
now i want you to come and come to
dinner
i wonder if that will boil over at some
point or come back around or if jordan
is just going to be the best guy
about it probably
hey and you know some of you guys might
get mad at me for saying that [ __ ] but i
remember when that whole thing was
happening with like lana talking with
sarah in the garage
being like he doesn't deserve you if he
won't take you back i remember when that
was happening i saw all them comments
you guys mean like yo [ __ ] lana and
this is i hate how the show just expects
me to forgive sarah so fast
i haven't forgotten
i ride that anger and ride those rage
clicks that's how you guys come here to
superman and lois yeah right
rage against sarah yeah that's why you
guys come here i get it i'm baiting you
in with that 10 minutes sarah ran i
don't really give a [ __ ]
do whatever she wants i support her in
fact
actually you have to tell jordan
who cares
she should just have two relationships
completely oblivious to one another if
she didn't have powers if he didn't have
powers
he wouldn't
take two if she take three
she does not know he has powers so
she could just put this all behind his
back because just gotten smooth sailing
like nothing
man could even kept hooking up with her
that's right sarah's an idiot that's
where this [ __ ] is
yeah there's an idiot we need sarah to
become euphoria
cop on you for you
on season two yet yes right just binged
at all all of it where are you on you
for you
uh the menu of the hbo max app
how can you say become euphorio if you
haven't seen euphoria john because the
only thing people talk about in
relationship to uh euphoria is like the
abundance of like pulpy uh sexual
material so i can only assume
that uh that's if you're a freaking
pansy
which i am and you gotta look away i am
i do otherwise i would have given
euphoria pg rating
because we just censor our kids too much
yeah it should be on freaking
channel sev abc abc is your family
for you teach your kids some [ __ ] once
in a while yeah yeah yeah anyway guys do
you think sarah should keep on cheating
leave your thoughts down below thanks
for being here
yes
john henry and natalie moved out too i
don't
you if you're cool with everything i'm
not really that pissed i'm just
you're going to turn the camera off and
go back and just oh glower these people
trying to forgive this [ __ ] oh yeah
natalie man you know grumpy grumpy
natalie well that's something where i
felt like that could have been as as
much as i can appreciate the performers
i'm like if they had maybe made
that back and forth like the main
subplot of an episode or something like
that uh you know i mean it's like nice
to see her out not nice but you know
like it does something it gives an
effect to her emotional state to see her
stranded out in space and all that stuff
but i feel like if that had really if
this had really been again it's like you
said there's so many things going on
that it doesn't feel as as much of a
like a tuned in wrap around as it could
have if this episode like really kind of
honed in on oh john's back and then
natalie's having this you know struggle
it sort of feels like this thing that's
been kind of happening as a sidebar for
the past several episodes that now
finally got kind of pushed forward
but
all i got from what you said was that
you seem to have more qualms with that
than with
sarah
wanting
jordan to meet up with the person she
cheated on him with like somehow you
just rattle off
a whole bunch of issues with that
without taking even a second to go you
know i kind of get where natalie's
coming from and i like that they
explored why absolutely a lot of her
grudging behavior came from and when
like oh that's why she would behave like
she has a stick up harassment and it
makes a lot of sense totally you know
when you think about it
but boom just
only problems only problems with that
but the second i say something about
sarah you're like yeah i guess sure
maybe yeah oh whatever yeah that's fine
like
yeah yeah
so it's extremely [ __ ] up so well
whatever around yeah it's kind of fun i
hope sarah dies in the next episode
thanks because sarah
sarah's actually half white jordan
you can pick that car up and just drop
it on her
that's too far
do you learn how to forget people once
in a while
all right guys thanks for being here and
uh we'll catch you guys
soon
[Music]